what's going on reject nation greg here
we're going to watch the justice league
snyder cut flash
character trailer watch that ezra miller
run that
that like loose loose hands run thing
that he does
just me today john's working on stuff at
home at the moment but i'm very excited
about this i feel like some truly new
unexplored stuff will come from
the flash portrayal come from all the
characters but something tells me that
with this specific tease like when i
think about the original justice league
trailer before there was ever a jaw
sweden involved in the picture think
about scenes that the flash was in that
were not in the joss whedon cut so let's
see what they got here today it's only
about a minute long
i want you to listen to being married
because i mean
yes
shoes
iris looks upon him with so much
like wonder
[Music]
you're just shredding the ground
make your own future make your own past
wonder what he's gonna i wonder what
that specific scene is what
specifically that final moment is i know
he's supposed to be going into the speed
force at some point in this movie and
then as we saw on bvs
you know what i'm gonna watch this
trailer again
there's so much detail here
there's so much detail
[Music]
he's gonna change some [ __ ]
he's gonna do some barry allen [ __ ]
where he changes some [ __ ] in the
timeline
[Laughter]
[Music]
the tension and detail here and the
visual effects is so
good with his shoes tearing apart he
runs in a way like when he has to save
iris west
he has to be it's just so delicate even
when he's like running up to her
this is clearly a necessity for the suit
when he gets his actual flash suit
because clearly this is the beginning
he's like a super powerful flash
but he doesn't really have proper
control over everything so
any little thing that he does he's like
learning in this movie and you see it in
this sequence like just from the way he
puts iris west down
he's trying his best to be incredibly
gentle because it seems like when he's
trying to do some things he's naturally
destroying stuff whether it be shredding
the ground
is his shoes tearing apart every little
bit of movement
that he does you know it was kind of
brushed over it was like a little
character set up in the joss whedon cut
like a big part of
his backstory is that his dad was framed
for the murder of his
of his mom it's really just a it's just
a little thing
that joss whedon cut right i really feel
like that's a big part of his
emotional tale here in the snyder cut of
what we'll be focusing in on you feel a
lot more of that depth because
i find it interesting when that joss
reading version came out not everyone
shares this opinion all right i know not
everyone shares his opinion i do
think that's a lot of people though i
would venture to say
majority even if that's like 60 to 70
percent
even people who didn't like that joss
whedon cut did say that one of the
better parts of the movie
was ezra miller's flash like he was
really funny in the movie yes that's
like what i got from the character was
that he was really funny he had some
really funny scenes
i'm sure he'll still have some really
humorous moments here
but what i really got just from even in
that final moment which i think is
dealing with the speed force i feel like
uh you will get
much more of that emotional
depth a lot more of that pain that barry
allen actually has to carry
oh yes he's kind of socially awkward
he's really smart
very intelligent he's funny but the man
also has
a [ __ ] ton of pain in his life i think
that's something that i even this one is
like one
still that i have right here on screen
you can just see it in his eyes
there's this much bigger range of depth
here than
any moment that we got in that josh
whedon cut
so i'm very much excited to see
what he does and i'm also really excited
for iris west
because iris west is not in the justice
league version at all i don't think
she's in this
a lot but she's such a big part to
barry allen she's such a big part of the
story for
like who barry allen is and we're also
getting the flash moving now i don't
know if i was supposed to be in an
adventure to say she
she is i like that that movie seems to
just be changing all the damn time
and it seems like it's actually getting
made now so i don't i'm not
really sure what the full extent of the
details are with that i'm kind of just
at the point i'm like it was way to see
a trailer
because i can't really tell what this
movie's gonna turn out to be but what's
cool is that
i think this trailer out of all the solo
ones that we've gotten
you know like the flash isn't my
favorite character but out of the
solo ones that we've got and this is
actually
i venture to say that the best one it
felt the most
like wow there's a lot of like these
scenes
allude to a lot of like plot points
that are not in the joss whedon cut
at all like all this stuff with the
saving iris west being heroic the speed
force at the
uh all that is not in that other version
to me i thought for the one minute and
also enhancing the character
of barry allen as opposed to just being
funny ezra miller to me this is actually
the most effective
inch in a one minute tease
i think you know batman and super one
really got me talking though
but at the same time you know with the
flash movie actually being made now
i think this that snyderco can get
people very excited
for for that solo movie again i'm
anticipating it i'm looking forward to
it
uh but i think like you know this will
give everyone a chance to really shine
and uh yeah get some iris west action
here man issues tore apart that was cool
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below what you think of this this
little trailer
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
patron of the day shout out
anissa oliva you've got me of course i
wear this snyder cut shirt that you got
me like all the time but because this is
a flash specific trailer i was like let
me wear my flash shirt but i love that
snyder cut shirt you gave me i
wear a lot of shirts that you've given
me but beyond that i wanted to shout you
out specifically
because if there's anyone who's like the
flash at our patreon page
it's you you're there for us in the nick
of time
whenever the hell we need you even when
you're working at an er
you'll still find time to hop online and
chit chat with us
it doesn't matter you're you're
constantly there for us so i'm trying to
say this
i'm iris west in the situation you're
barry
allen role reversal we're in a new age
now anissa
woke times you're barry allen in the
scenario anyway nissa you're the best
i love you texas the weather's been
batshit crazy lately
but i hope that when all said and done
that
you're you're able to enjoy the weather
and snow for what it is despite
some of the terrible things that have
occurred there as of late you rock
i love you talk to you soon